you do not have much patience with
people that blame call me or blame the
Russian hacking is that true yeah look
you really hate talking to me like a
second yeah look I think that the
Russians mess with our election I think
that's terrible and I wish that the
president-elect would act like something
bad happened to our country that would
be I don't know presidential and also
patriotic so I wish the president-elect
would say something about that I think
that Comey did a terrible job he
violated his own principles etc she's
running against a cartoon character she
should have won all 50 states so I want
to talk about the other 1,300 reasons
right it was not a game those were not
game changers for you yes listen if you
are doing the right things as a
candidate look at the counties that flip
they're 200 counties that went from red
to blue you go in those counties those
counties in general we're not people who
were fired up by the alt-right
in the white nationalist and the
horrific Islamophobia those kept there
were counties like that but those
counties were already banked for the
Republicans the counties that we lost
were people who were concerned that the
the jobs weren't coming back that they
weren't being spoken to effectively and
appropriately there are people who felt
that maybe they didn't fit into the
Democratic coalition anymore and she
never visited didn't go there didn't go
so look do I am I happy that we have
this guy's president no I'm not but you
never win the championship criticizing
the other team you win the championship
by looking at yourself and what can you
do better and right now liberals are
throwing a big pity party if you point
out there's one thing we could have done
better
could have done better they say well you
know you are somehow now an apologist
for the Trump people right and I'm
saying no first of all the Trump people
are a lot of people some liked all that
nasty stuff you know what a lot of them
say they said I wish he didn't talk that
way I don't agree with him on those
issues but nobody cares about me nobody
came to my County Trump came right now
if you can accept
that some people can find bad the
inflammatory nasty things distasteful
but not disqualifying you can keep your
heart open to them and pull them closer
instead we're calling them all bad names
are pushing them away we got stuff
you